[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und marietta slomka
guten abend heute abend beriet sich
us-präsident beiden in einer kurzfristig
anberaumten video konferenz mit den
europäern wie umgehen mit dem russischen
truppenaufmarsch und was genau hat
moskau vor die ukraine einschüchtern den
westen austesten den machtanspruch in
der region demonstrieren oder
tatsächlich einmarschieren putin mag die
welt in atem halten und im unklaren
lassen über seine absichten und man mag
im kreml zufrieden sein über den aufruhr
und die offenkundige uneinigkeit des
westens doch auch putin hat ein problem
wer derart laut mit den säbeln gerasselt
kann sich schlecht einfach wieder
einpacken und sang und klanglos abziehen
im augenblick provoziert er vor allem
gegendruck anne gellinek berichtet
es soll ein tag der klaren botschaften
in europa sein und zumindest hier bei
der nato klappt das auch am nachmittag
trifft nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg
die außenminister von schweden und
finnland beide sind nachbarn von
russland beide keine nato mitglieder und
beide haben angst
lassen sie mich betonen wie ernsthaft
besorgt wir sind über russlands
aufmarsch an der ukrainischen grenze und
seine aggressive rhetorik
es ist jetzt schon der schlimmste
konflikt im modernen europa
beitreten wollen die beiden nordländer
trotzdem nicht gemeinsame truppenübungen
mit der nato aber schon europa übt sich
in abschreckung diesem ziel soll auch
die ankündigung des generalsekretärs
dienen die militärpräsenz des bündnisses
in osteuropa zu verstärken schiffe
flugzeuge kampfverbände sollen nach
bulgarien rumänien und litauen geschickt
werden um die lage an der
russisch-ukrainischen grenze zu
überwachen
wir stoppen unsere truppen auf aber nur
zu unserer verteidigung wir bedrohen
russland nicht unsere reaktion ist
angemessen geschmack kreml sprecher
dimitri peskow sieht das im
radiointerview anders
was konkrete taten angeht so sehen wir
ja was die nato an erklärungen abgibt
sie erhöhen truppenkontingente und zieht
kräfte an der ostflanke zusammen und das
führt schon noch mehr spannungen
auch die eu-außenminister bemühen sich
in brüssel um klare botschaften
allerdings mit weniger erfolg umstritten
ist die frage welche sanktionen die
europäer verhängen würden im falle einer
russischen aggression die härteste von
allen das abkoppeln russlands vom
finanzsystem swift würde deutschland
auch hart treffen weil der handel mit
russland nicht mehr bezahlt werden
könnte ich hatte ja bereits deutlich
gemacht dass der härteste knüppel nicht
immer das intelligenteste schwert am
ende sein wird sondern wir
finanzmaßnahmen so überprüfen müssen
dass sie die größte wirkung entfalten
streit auch beim thema waffenlieferungen
an die ukraine die deutsche ablehnung
sorgte in europa für kopfschütteln die
neue regierung brauche wohl noch zeit um
anzukommen
in berlin findet sich in einer
schwierigen situation wieder 16 jahre
lang war deutschland ein
stabilitätsanker in und für europa und
was wir jetzt sehen ist eine
innerdeutsche diskussion die man auf
diese neue situation reagieren sollen
ich habe geduld und rufe zu geduld auf
[Musik]
am abend schalten sich die
transatlantischen verbündeten zusammen
präsident biden spricht mit
bundeskanzler scholz dem französischen
präsidenten dem britischen premier und
den spitzen von eu und nato
herauskommen soll man ahnt es eine klare
botschaft des westens an russland
tja von diesen transatlantischen
gesprächen jetzt am abend ist noch nicht
viel bekannt geworden aber immerhin es
gibt eine botschaft nämlich dass der
deutsche bundeskanzler im februar in
washington erwartet wird außerdem haben
die usa 800.000 soldaten in
alarmbereitschaft gestellt und das
normandie format das sogenannte soll
wieder aufgenommen werden da soll es
schon am mittwoch erste treffen geben
jetzt sollten wir noch nach moskau zu
unserem korrespondenten axel sturm axel
in moskau klingt das ja mal alles so als
sei eigentlich russland das land das mit
einer aggression konfrontiert wird
ja das zumindest ist die lesart hier die
der kreml gerne kommuniziert gerne und
oft kommuniziert aber hier in russland
sieht man die welt ja sowieso ganz
anders als im westen das ist nichts
neues aber das kann man jeden tag
erleben zum beispiel auf der facebook
seite des auswärtigen amtes oder eben
durch statements wie das gehörte von
kreml sprecher pierce kopf der sagte
durch gezielte informationskampagnen und
durch konkrete handlung verschärften die
nato und der westen den konflikt um die
ukraine wohlgemerkt es geht um einen
konflikte erst entstanden ist durch die
massive truppen konzentrieren russischer
soldaten an der grenze zur ukraine und
was hört man aktuell aus der ukraine von
der ukrainischen regierung
ja widersprüchliche signale
es gab heute im laufe des tages mal die
meldung dass präsident selensky
kommuniziert habe er werde im falle
einer russischen aggression dafür sorgen
dass sich sein land offensivverteidiger
sendete aber auch widersprüchliches aus
im laufe des tages dann gab es die
nachricht dass er in kiew zur ruhe
aufgerufen habe er habe dafür geworben
nicht in panik zu verfallen die
situation sei seit 2014 schon sehr
angespannt dass er alles unter kontrolle
es ist eben auch sind die zeiten der
unklaren signale und der turbo
diplomatie und das kann man jeden tag
erleben sowohl in kiew als auch hier in
moskau stichwort turbo diplomatie jetzt
versuchen wir doch noch mal nach brüssel
zu schalten für unsere korrespondentin
anne gellinek das hat nämlich eben
nicht geklappt sieht jetzt auch nicht so
richtig gut aus
besser spät als nie hallo ich
habe eben schon gesagt von dem
transatlantischen gesprächen vom abend
hört man nicht so viel konkretes oder
[Musik]
meinen die fanden in hermetisch
abgeschirmte und in washington auch in
einem abhörsicheren raum statt aber
trotzdem sind im umfeld ein paar
informationen durchgesickert oder sagen
wir besser platziert worden das eine ist
dass der sprecher des amerikanischen
verteidigungsministeriums angekündigt
hat das 8500 amerikanische soldaten in
einsatzbereitschaft versetzt worden sind
damit sie im notfall der nato geschickt
werden können nach europa entsandt
werden können und das zweite ist dass
das neue format am mittwoch wieder in
paris tagen wird das heißt dass zum
ersten mal
eine und russland sich wieder an einem
tisch gegenüber sitzen unter vermittlung
von deutschland und frankreich und die
situation um die ukraine direkt
besprechen können insgesamt platte doch
der eindruck dass da einer großen
uneinigkeit in europa und auch teils
verstimmung speziell über deutschland
ja es gab heute bei den beim treffen der
europäischen außenminister schon das
gefühl dass deutschland nicht so richtig
mitzieht die strikte ablehnung
deutschlands waffen defensive
verteidigungswaffen an die ukraine zu
liefern die sorgte hier doch sowohl bei
den amerikanischen verbündeten als auch
bei einigen europäern verständnis und
dann ist da noch in um nord stream zwei
ob die zug awp die gaspipeline als
sanktion taugt und diese diskussion die
innerhalb berlins innerhalb der
koalition geführt wird wird hier in
europa sehr deutlich und sehr mit sehr
viel sorgfalt betrachtet und es gibt
schon den deutlichen wunsch hier in
europa dass deutschland mit einer
einigen einer geeinten position hier
bald wieder auftauchen
dankeschön nach brüssel eine klinik und
dann kommen wir zu dem anderen großen
thema unserer zeit die korona lage das
omikron in besonderem maße durch die
schulen rauscht macht es vielerorts
zunehmend schwer den regulären
präsenzunterricht den ja die
kultusminister versprochen haben in der
praxis auch tatsächlich aufrecht zu
erhalten hinzu kommt dass nicht alle
eltern und lehrkräfte mit dem
einverstanden sind was gemeinhin als
durchseuchung strategie bezeichnet wird
die stadt berlin zieht jetzt die
notbremse sie hebt die präsenzpflicht an
den schulen auf und überlässt damit den
eltern die entscheidung
beim bund länder treffen heute scheint
die thematik keine größere rolle
gespielt zu haben im vordergrund standen
mangelnde pcr tests die impfpflicht
debatte und
zukunftshoffnungen klaus brodbeck
berichtet
gleich zu beginn ein eingeständnis wenn
noch verpackt mit dem impfen läuft es
noch immer nicht wie erhofft noch
stärker soll nun dafür getrommelt werden
impfen hilft dass es nur ein ganz
kleiner auszug von dem was wir uns
vorgenommen haben das kommt noch viele
viele andere dazu vom radio spot zur
benutzung der
kommunikationsmöglichkeiten die sich mit
social media verbinden kommen nur heraus
aus den ständigen wiederholungen von law
und lockerungen wenn mehr menschen
geimpft sind wir haben in deutschland
aktuell eine impfquote von 75 das ist
schlicht noch zu wenig fast schon
demonstrativ die einigkeit hier nur
mühsam beigelegt dagegen der konflikt um
die entscheidung des
robert-koch-instituts unerwartet den
status von genießen herabzustufen den
gesundheitsminister brachte das unter
druck
solche änderungen brauchen einen
angemessenen vorlauf die menschen müssen
sich darauf auch ein stück vorbereiten
können zu einer vorausschauenden
pandemie politik gehört eben auch
verlässlichkeit in zukunft zwei wochen
vorlaufzeit hatten die länder noch am
nachmittag gefordert beim bund jedoch
letzten sie damit ab es kann damit aber
nicht rechnen situationen geben die
erfordern das sofort gehandelt werden
muss aber sofort auch alle informiert
werden auch alle politischen
entscheidungsträger weil sich dramatisch
etwas ändert das kann auf schnitt kostet
aufschub erlaubt und es kann situationen
geben wo wir durchaus noch die zeit
haben ein vorlauf prozess zu
organisieren dringend neu organisiert
werden soll auch der umgang mit pcr
tests die inzwischen knapp geworden sind
es ist ganz klar dass mit den erhöhten
zahlen wir eben nicht mehr einfach
genauso weiter testen wie wir das bisher
getan haben dass es eine fokussierung
braucht eine schwerpunktsetzung bei den
pcr tests auf diejenigen die mit den
ganz besonders honorable in
gruppenarbeiten kliniken
pflegeeinrichtungen gehören dazu aber
auch die sogenannte kritische
infrastruktur etwa polizei oder
nahverkehr beides in berlin bereits
eingeschränkt weil beschäftigte krank
oder in quarantäne sind auch die
präsenzpflicht an schulen hebt die
hauptstadt ab morgen auf das ist einfach
jetzt ein weg um den verschiedenen
bedürfnissen die wir hier an dieser
stelle sehen kinderbetreuung
aufrechterhalten auf der anderen seite
den sorgen der eltern zu entsprechen
auch hier gerecht zu werden bund und
länder kündigen an öffnungs perspektiven
zu entwickeln sobald die überlastung des
gesundheitssystems ausgeschlossen werden
kann leichter wird es nicht
beschäftigung mit lockerungen das wäre
glaube ich in der gegenwärtigen
situation etwas eigentlich wenn wir dann
konkrete diskussion über konkrete
maßnahmen führen würden denn wir erleben
ja gerade neue hochs bei den
infektionszahlen und wir wissen dass
weitere hinzukommen werden am 16 februar
wollen sie wieder beraten womöglich aber
auch ihr eingeständnis zum schluss
vorhersagen könnte man nichts
für die stadt heidelberg speziell für
ihre universität war das heute ein
furchtbarer tag an dem eine junge frau
ihr leben verloren hat auch der 18
jährige täter ist tot darüber hinaus
mehrere menschen verletzt und viele
weitere traumatisiert der tathergang auf
dem universitätscampus wirkt wie ein
amoklauf so wie man es eher von schulen
kennt aber noch ist sehr vieles unklar
seien class fasst zusammen was bisher an
informationen gibt
es ist dieses gebäude der universität
heidelberg in dem am mittag
unvorstellbares passiert in dem ein
junger mann selbst student an der
universität in einem hörsaal stürmt und
schießt auf andere studierende
der 18 jährige deutsche mutmaßliche
täter ging mit zwei langwaffen bewaffnet
mit einer doppel blinder mit einer redet
ihr waffe ging er in den hörsaal
und hat mehrfach geschossen und hat
dabei vier personen verletzt eine person
so schwer dass sie gegen 16 uhr die
mitteilung kam vom krankenhaus das sie
verstorben ist der mutmaßliche täter
flieht nach der tat aus dem gebäude
erschießt sich wenige meter entfernt
selbst in seinem rucksack fanden die
ermittler später noch rund 100 patronen
ob er seine opfer gezielt ausgewählt hat
ob er noch mehr menschen töten wollte im
moment noch unklar
wir konnten bisher nachweisen dass er
unmittelbar vor der tat eine woche an
jemand geschrieben hat
und darin berichtet hat
dass leute jetzt bestraft werden müssen
werden alle freunde bekannte
familienangehörige vornehmen und uns
dann versuchen ein bild zu machen von
seinem motiv lager war es gibt natürlich
auch jetzt schon hinweise darauf dass
lange zurückliegend mal eine psychische
erkrankung vorgelegen hat und auch der
werden wir nach diesem hinweis nach
bisherigen erkenntnissen ist der
18-jährige ein einzeltäter war der
polizei zuvor nicht bekannt die waffen
hatte er vor wenigen tagen im ausland
erworben ohne einen waffenschein zu
besitzen seine tat löst eine schockwelle
aus auch weit über die universität weit
über heidelberg hinaus
geschockt ich glaube das ist das wort
das sich damals gebraucht habe ich bin
absolut geschockt und kann immer noch
nicht realisieren was dann genau
passiert das wenn wir uns das vorstellen
dass junge menschen in einem hörsaal
angegriffen werden ohne dass sie
irgendwie darauf vorbereitet waren und
miterleben müssen wie kommilitonen und
kommilitonen
eine zumindest verstirbt das ist etwas
was man sich eigentlich als
familienvater als oberbürgermeister gar
nicht schlimmer vorstellen kann es
zerreißt mir das herz solch eine
nachricht zu erfahren man dabei lloyd
ist bei den angehörigen und den opfern
und natürlich bei den studentinnen und
studenten der universität
heidelberg versucht zu verstehen
irgendwie zu begreifen was da heute
geschehen ist das verarbeiten wird
dauern die arbeit der ermittler aber
auch die der seelsorger hat gerade erst
begonnen und
jetzt macht gundula mit den nachrichten
weiter da geht es erst noch einmal und
rohner die weltgesundheitsorganisation
hat vor möglichen neuen varianten des
virus gewarnt whu chef gabriel soz
mahnte es sei gefährlich anzunehmen dass
omikron die letzte variante und die
pandemie damit praktisch vorbei sei die
akute phase könnte jedoch in diesem jahr
beendet werden wenn das whu ziel einer
weltweiten impfquote von 70 prozent
erreicht würde dem robert koch institut
wurden 63 1393 neue fälle gemeldet
29 1248 mehr als am vergangenen montag
die sieben tage incident stieg auf 8
140,3 die hospitalisierung rate ist
weiter relativ niedrig aktuell bei
3,87
bundespräsident steinmeier hat
gewaltsame proteste gegen die staatliche
corona politik als gefahr für den
sozialen frieden verurteilt hass und
gewalt zerstört das fundament unseres
miteinander sagte er in schloss bellevue
mitarbeiterinnen von arztpraxen und
politiker beschrieben eine
weitverbreitete gereiztheit und attacken
wegen corona aufladen sie forderten
unter anderem polizeischutz für
kommunalpolitiker wie sich bedroht
fühlen
der frühere papst benedikt hat eine
wesentliche aussage zum münchner
missbrauchs gutachten korrigiert anders
als zunächst behauptet habe er 1980 als
erzbischof doch an einer sitzung
teilgenommen bei der es laut gutachtern
um einen priester ging dem
kindesmissbrauch vorgeworfen wurde
benedikt privatsekretär gänswein sprach
von einem fehler der benedikt sehr leid
tue allerdings sei bei der sitzung nicht
über einen seelsorgerischen einsatz des
mannes entschieden worden sondern über
eine unterkunft während der
therapeutischen behandlung des priesters
in münchen
im westafrikanischen burkina faso hat
die armee nach eigenen angaben die
regierung gestürzt und die macht
übernommen trotz seiner gold vorkommen
ist burkina faso eines der weltweit
ärmsten länder zudem leidet die
zivilbevölkerung unter der gewalt
islamistische milizen präsident kaboré
habe versagt so die meuternden soldaten
auf den straßen von ouagadougou wurde
der sturz der regierung gefeiert
erstmals seit der rückkehr der taliban
an die macht in afghanistan führen
wiesen führen westliche vertreter
offizielle gespräche mit einer
delegation der islamisten in norwegens
hauptstadt oslo geht es hinter
verschlossenen türen um die humanitäre
lage in afghanistan die taliban
delegierten werden dabei auf die
freigabe von 88 milliarden euro drängen
die unter anderem in den usa eingefroren
sind den westlichen diplomaten soll es
vor allem um die rechte von frauen in
afghanistan
angehen
seit 2005 ist das amt der oder des
integrationsbeauftragten der
bundesregierung direkt ins kanzleramt
gezogen im range eines staatsministers
beziehungsweise ministerin eine
deutliche aufwertung früher waren die
integrationsbeauftragten dem familien-
oder sozialministerium zugeordnet und
hießen noch
ausländerbeauftragte was begrifflich
sehr gut zeigt wie sich das politische
verständnis von einwanderung verändert
hat die amtsträgerin der neuen ampel
regierung realer bali radovan ist die
jüngste die dieses amt innehatte sie ist
ostdeutsche mecklenburgerin ihre familie
flüchtete aus dem irak ihre ersten
lebensjahre verbrachte sie in russland
ein porträt von bernd mosebach
friedrichstraße schwerin dieser kleine
laden stand bisher leer jetzt gibt es
hier eine neue mieterin
so dass losgehen ich denke mal märz wird
es dann so richtig los gehen ja neben
aller galli radovan hat sich eine
exponierte lage ausgesucht drei häuser
weiter das bürgerbüro dfd
dass wir auch hier einziehen um zu
zeigen dass wir es nicht bestimmt leuten
überlassen sondern auch ganz präsent in
der stadt sind vor zwei jahren wird sie
integrationsbeauftragte in mecklenburg
vorpommern vor einem jahr tritt sie in
die spd ein gewinnt direkt ihr
bundestagsmandat jetzt seit ein paar
wochen ist sie die
integrationsbeauftragte der
bundesregierung im rang einer
staatsministerin eine blitzkarriere auch
den sprung zur integrationsbeauftragten
des landes war groß vorher war ich auch
die büroleiterin meiner vorgängerin und
da habe ich quasi das ganze schon mal
erlebt wie es ist auf einmal eine
verantwortung zu übernehmen
verantwortung für die migrations
flüchtlings und integrationspolitik im
rot grün gelben kabinett von olaf scholz
die 31 jährige auf dem weg zu einer frau
die nicht ganz unschuldig ist in ihrem
aufstieg
antrittbesuch der staatsministerin in
der staatskanzlei bei manuela schwesig
die partei freundinnen teilen sich
übrigens künftig das bürgerbüro in der
stadt mir war schon immer wichtig dass
man nicht erst 20 jahre lang 100 tausend
plakate für die spd geklebt haben muss
bevor man eigentlich in verantwortung
kommen sechs jahre ist sie alt als die
flucht ihrer familie aus dem irak über
moskau in mecklenburg vorpommern endet
in einer flüchtlingsunterkunft beginnt
ihr neues leben politisches asyl
deutsche staatsbürgerschaft abitur
politikstudium ihre integration
beschreibt sie als gelungen will aber
bitte nicht als vorzeige migrantin
gelten heute wohnt sie mit ihrem mann
einem profi boxer in schwerin nennt die
stadt ihre heimat so sieht sie sich als
junge frau aus ostdeutschland mit
einwanderungsgeschichte
gibt es da was von den drei dingen die
besonders nach vorne gehen bei ihnen wie
ich finde alles gehört zusammen ich
finde man kann so was nicht abtrennen
und quasi sagen dass ostdeutsche
überwiegt oder die
einwanderungsgeschichte oder mein alter
sondern es ist ein zusammenspiel aus
allem
kanzleramt vierter stock reben aller
bali radovan hat sich viel vorgenommen
in ihrem neuen amt
büro ein modernes
staatsangehörigkeitsgesetz diversität
bessere beratungsangebote für opfer von
rassismus und vor allem sagt sie der
kampf gegen rechts
und so ist sie angekommen die junge frau
aus ostdeutschland mit
einwanderungsgeschichte im zentrum der
macht
er macht jetzt noch mal weiter und
fährst du mit dem blick nach italien
dort hat die erste runde der wahl eines
neuen staatspräsidenten in rom wie
erwartet kein ergebnis gebracht die
notwendige zweidrittelmehrheit kam nicht
zustande
als favorit der auf mehrere tage
angesetzten wahl gilt italiens
amtierender regierungschef mario draghi
noch aber gibt es unter den über 1000
wahlleuten keine einigung ab dem vierten
wahlgang wohl am donnerstag reicht eine
einfache mehrheit von 505 stimmen
zu wirtschaft und finanzen eine
notbremse des wirtschaftsministeriums
der sofortige stopp der staatlichen
förderung von energieeffizienz für
neubauten hat massive kritik der
wohnungswirtschaft und der hausbauer
ausgelöst frank bethmann warum genau und
was bedeutet das für die antragsteller
das hat zuletzt einfach einen enormen
run auf die förderung die geben laut kfw
ging in den zurückliegenden wochen
anträge in höhe von 20 milliarden euro
bei der staatseigenen bank ein auch weil
ein förderprogramm ausläuft das hat die
zur verfügung stehenden mittel deutlich
überstiegen deshalb jetzt der sofortige
stopp betroffen die förderung für die
effizienzhäuser 55 und dh 40 die
einstufung bedeutet dass die neubauten
nur 55 bzw 40 prozent der energie
verbrauchen die einen standard haus
benötigt nach angaben des ministeriums
ist noch nicht entschieden was jetzt mit
den eingegangenen aber noch nicht
bewilligten anträgen geschieht geprüft
werden alternativen wie zinsverbilligte
kredite insgesamt wolle man die
förderung nun neu ordnen für viele die
jetzt gerade bauen wollen vermutlich
aber nur ein schwacher trost wir müssen
heute auch über das deutliche minus des
dachs reden dahinter stehen nicht nur
sorgen wegen der ukraine konflikts ja
die sorgen spielten auch eine rolle aber
hinzu kommen die befürchtungen dass die
us notenbank die leitzinsen erhöht
morgen kommt die fed zu einer
zweitägigen sitzung zusammen heute
bereits reagiert der dax verliert zum
handelsschluss 3,8 prozent oder über 590
punkte ein ausverkauf der nur eine
interpretation zulässt die inflation in
den usa ist inzwischen einfach zu hoch
eine leitzinserhöhung steht unmittelbar
bevor und da sagen sich viele anleger
dann lieber umschichten in
festverzinsliche papiere und raus aus
ihres kanten aktien von bethmann vielen
dank
in berlin sind die sterne des sports für
besonderes gesellschaftliches engagement
verliehen worden wegen corona erneut im
online format bundespräsident steinmeier
würdigte mit dem ersten preis dotiert
mit 10.000 euro den verein kongress new
sports aus halle der sportverein bietet
jugendlichen aus der skateboard und bmx
szene
freizeitangebote und
perspektiven
er war ein kreatives multitalent vor
allem einer der bekanntesten
französischen modeschöpfer thierry
mugler ist im alter von 73 jahren
gestorben
mit seinen extravaganten entwürfen
prägte mit lehre ab den 1980 er jahren
die modewelt
futuristisch die schnitte ungewöhnlich
die verwendeten materialien möglich
arbeitete auch als regisseur autor und
designer ungebrochen der schaffensdrang
des straße was geben so die treue der
stars zu sein
ja das war es von uns gleich nach dem
wetter geht es im montagskino beitragen
und direkt danach um 0.50 gibt es hier
eine heute express ist morgen auf
wiedersehen tschüs
[Musik]
guten abend an weihnachten ist das
weltraumteleskop james webb ins all
gestartet seine mission das universum
erforschen unbekannte galaxien
exoplaneten gar auf denen leben möglich
wäre jetzt kommt das teleskop an seinem
einsatzort an rund 1,5 millionen
kilometer von der erde entfernt am lagos
punkt l2 einem gleichgewichts punkt im
system sonne erde fast antriebslos kann
es dort rotieren ohne richtung erde
zurück zu fallen oder im universum zu
verschwinden auf der sonnenseite des
schutzschildes liegt die temperatur bei
85 grad die empfindlichen messgeräte
untersuchung bei gut gekühlten minus 233
grad von der schattenseite aus das
universum
unfassbar sind solche großen
temperaturunterschiede bei uns auf der
erde unserer atmosphäre sei dank die
temperaturen heute nacht sinken am
alpenrand auf minus 8 grad im nordosten
bleibt es bei 4 bis 3 grad deutlich
milder
dort kann es auch ein bisschen nieseln
im süden bildet sich wieder nebel morgen
über tag ändert sich wenig es gibt
entweder strahlende sonnenschein oder
nebelfelder und im nordosten bleibt es
meist bedeckt mit etwas nieselregen oder
etwas schneeregen im erzgebirge die
temperaturen liegen zwischen 1 grad hier
im vogtland und 8 grad am oberrhein am
mittwoch ändert sich an diesem wetter
wenig am donnerstag kommt dann ein
sturmtief guten abend